they locked you in your home when you
should have been outside right that was
a terrible mistake they gave you a novel
vaccine when you should have been taking
vitamin D right
across the board they did the inverse of
the right thing and we still don't know
why so my point really well we I mean
yeah we can I think it's pretty fair to
say
why
if you know I want to know I'm still not
sure I know
well I mean to to sell vaccines
um right even though they were free to
the public the government's coffering up
the cash for it
um so yeah to absolutely to sell
vaccines I mean and here I mean the
evidence to that I see that shows that I
mean it's
seems kind of obvious but one um
specific instance was you're probably
from are you familiar with how
natural immunity was removed from the
whose website
so that tells me and also the timing of
it Brett the timing of it
um it was removed I believe just uh
before or just after
um the Pfizer's first uh press release
on trials for the vaccine so I mean it's
just the correlation's pretty pretty
amazing there
um and then all of a sudden they removed
it completely they did bring it back uh
maybe a month or so later
after the emergency authorization
right and it's just so amazing and uh
they also brought it back
um
on New Year's Eve when most people
wouldn't really notice and also
um and they did and they also brought it
back they had a different you know
context saying that they do not think or
advocate for treating or curing the
pandemic with natural immunity but
vaccines so they they changed that
that's when they brought it back of
course okay but let's go back to your
premise
they did it to sell vaccines
that makes logical sense to me
but I find it so shocking given the
danger involved in inoculating people
with this highly novel gene therapy
technology
the idea that they would
attempt to inoculate children
that they would push to have those
so-called vaccines put on the regular
vaccine schedule
that they would do so on the basis of
very little testing in some cases no
human testing at all
that is a level of indifference to harm
to other people's children that I find
very difficult to imagine
so are you saying that the the policy
that you saw simply makes sense to you
as people who don't care that they are
killing innocence
well I think the majority of people
advocating for vaccines for everybody
um
don't you know are not motivated to sell
more vaccines but I mean certainly we I
mean there's no question Pfizer is
motivated by profit
um
to sell more vaccines
and you know and then those in power you
know it's great political uh tool you
know it was a great weapon to wield
against Donald Trump right he's weak on
covid and covet is this you know
incredibly dangerous thing that's
life-threatening to everybody was the
way it was you know kind of framed
um so that's another motivation right
just political reasons
um
when as long as if you can fear Monger
if people are afraid they're easier to
control
um
and you and you keep your eyes glued to
the to the new the news more clicks
there's all these factors
um
yeah yeah I mean I see them too and you
know I've I know that I have said
many times that whatever motivated this
policy it is clear that the people who
architected it are completely
indifferent to the death of other people
yeah
um yeah so there is a part of me that
it's I think the problem is intuitively
it doesn't feel like it could be true
but logically speaking there's really no
next nearest competitor the in fact the
least worst explanation is that this was
simple greed
their explanations worse than that but
you know the floor is
they did it to sell vaccines and they
didn't care
who got hurt which
uh is an amazing fact to be if that's
really what's going on it is an amazing
thing to have witnessed
terrifying but is it's
happened before hasn't it uh with the
h1n
uh flu right
swine flu the vaccines right well yes on
the other hand in Prior cases we've
pulled vaccines from the market because
of safety signals that were a lot less
impressive than the one that the MRNA
vaccines generated so yeah yes it's not
nothing here is unprecedented including
indifference to the suffering and death
of other people but the scale of it the
scale of it
it boggles the mind
yeah
yeah I mean all happened on a global
scale I mean you had the who
saying
quote nobody is safe
until everybody is safe that was echoed
in the in the U.S media that's what it's
one of the mashups I've got in the works
and they just kept graffiti nobody is
safe
until everybody say when the reality was
at
99.5 percent of people were safe
at its worst almost everybody was safe
from the beginning and worse again this
is something that you won't be in a
position to to comment on in all
likelihood but
if we had done nothing
right no including not applied the very
good drugs that we had available to us
if we had simply done nothing
there is a pretty good likelihood that
this thing would have controlled itself
that now that we understand that the
proliferation of variance is actually
driven by this very narrow vaccination
campaign
we you know not only is the entire
pandemic likely a self-inflicted wound
with a laboratory Escape but what we did
compounded that self-inflicted when we
keep you know we keep inflicting new
wounds on ourselves and I I really I
think the
most important question in the entire
pandemic might be
uh
how much of the harm that was done here
after the thing was already spreading
was uh yatrogenic medically induced harm
that yes the cost would have been very
high many would have died
but would it have been more or fewer who
died if we had done nothing and just
simply allowed natural immunity to
accumulate
foreign
[Music]